Verse ton riz
et va apprendre ta leçon !
Bravo petit !
Un grand talibé m'a pris ma recette,
Tu te fiches de moi ?
Imbécile !
Pardon Serigne ! Aïe !
Tu n'as pas honte, après une journée
tu ne me ramènes que ça ?
Allez tricheur !
Files à tes leçons.
On n'a jamais vu ça !
J'ai ma recette !
Et alors ?
Baisses tes yeux de singe !
Donnes l'argent !
Les enseignants coraniques, au début,
ils disaient que j'attaquais l'islam.
Il a 16 ans que j'ai fait ce film,
il y a 16 ans qu'ils disent la même chose.
J'ai attaqué le business de la mendicité
des enfants, c'est ça que j'ai attaqué.
Je n'ai pas attaqué l'islam
je ne peux pas attaquer ma propre religion.
Mais maintenant,
c'est une réaction corporatiste.
Une réaction corporatiste qui disait que :
"Si tout le monde pense comme lui,
nous n'allons plus exister,
nous allons disparaître,
notre business va disparaître.
Si notre business disparaît,
on disparaît."
Non, il faut leur faire comprendre
que ce n'est pas négociable.
Mais ça ne veut pas dire
que vous allez disparaître.
Dites-nous les solutions !
Ensemble, nous chercherons une manière,
que vous puissiez gagner votre vie à travers
votre métier qui est d'enseigner le Coran.
Un métier, c'est pour pouvoir en vivre.
Donc qu'on ne dise pas qu'enseigner
le Coran doit être une activité gratuite.
Au fond, ce n'est pas gratuit
dans la mesure où c'est l'enfant qui paye.
Je pense qu'on a beau jeter l'opprobre
sur les marabouts et les maîtres coraniques,
je crois qu'il faut en jeter
le double sur nous-mêmes.
Nous sommes le carburant.
Talibé ! Viens ici !
C'est nous qui alimentons le problème.
Mais lui donner une bougie,
un sachet de lait et tout cela.
Ça, ça relève plutôt de ce
que j'appellerais vulgairement la sorcellerie.
Le charlatanisme a fait
que le citoyen sénégalais.
Et j'ai pourtant menti.
Je peux dire que tous les citoyens sénégalais
sont responsables parce que,
quand ils vont consulter un marabout
pour leur faire leurs actes,
ils doivent donner une charité.
Djiby ! Rangez vos tablettes !
Allez mendier !
Enseigner le Coran à un enfant
est une chose inestimable, merci !
Que Modou reste ici avec toi
pour bien apprendre le Coran.
Je te donne droit de vie
et de mort sur lui !
Merci pour ta confiance !
Je ferai de mon mieux pour Modou !
Cette scène, j'y tenais parce que
tout simplement, c'est au marché.
Le papa sait bien que le marabout
ne pourra pas entretenir son enfant,
et qu'il va le faire mendier,
il le sait bien.
Le marabout sait aussi que ce papa
lui a donné son enfant,
pour s'en débarrasser quelque part.
Chacun joue dans le registre religieux
en disant que :
"Dieu vous a donné la grande capacité
d'éduquer nos enfants de manière religieuse.
C'est vous qui détenez le Coran,
qu'on ne peut pas vous payer même pour ça."
C'est ce même discours qu'on est en train
de tenir à l'heure actuelle.
Si on ne se dit pas
que ça va exploser un jour,
car il ne faut pas faire
la politique de l'autruche.
Ils le pensent tout bas.
Je pense que l'Etat
s'y prend souvent très mal.
Des fois, ils attaquent
par un bout seulement,
plutôt que le problème global,
Je vous dis : Il y a le parent, il y a le
marabout, il y a l'État et il y a le citoyen.
Il faut qu'il y ait une sorte de commission,
je ne sais pas, moi, en tout cas,
un lieu de dialogue permanent,
où toutes ces entités
sont représentées et discutent,
mais de manière réaliste et vraie.
Gare à toi Djiby,
si tu dis un mot à Serigne !
J'ai voulu faire ce film
du point de vue de l'enfant,
en montrant que cet enfant
c'est un être humain,
et pas parce qu'il est jeune.
Moi, je développe toujours l'idée que
l'enfant met avec toute son intelligence.
À partir de ça, je me suis dit que ce gosse,
si j'essaie d'être dans son point de vue,
il va développer des choses en disant que :
"Je suis honnête comme toi,
j'ai le même droit que toi.
Pourquoi tu me tortures ?
Pourquoi tu me fais travailler ?
Pourquoi je n'ai pas le droit
à l'affection de ma maman ?
Pourquoi toi en tant que parent,
tu ne prends pas tes responsabilités ?"
À partir de ce moment,
j'en fais un être contestataire.
Finalement subversif.
Qu'il apprenne à travers ce film
à se prendre en charge,
à avoir le sens des responsabilités,
le sens de la dignité et le sens de la liberté.
Qu'on ne se fasse pas
faire des choses hors normes.
Si quelqu'un te fait des injustices,
refuse, révolte-toi !
Vos parents ne sont pas gentils sinon
ils ne vous laisseraient pas mendier.
... Ni manger de la m****
Moi, j'apprends le Coran à la maison,
Au fait, récitez-moi un verset !
Ne te fiche pas de nous !
Tu n'es pas notre marabout !
Vous êtes nuls !
C'est tout !
Tiens-moi ça,
que je lui casse la figure !